à l'extérieur comme à l'intérieur la
tour a fait peau neuve pour accueillir
des jardins en entrant les employés
longe d'abord une grande baie vitrée où
on peut voir l'enceinte du stade
après avoir traversé l'accueil ils
prennent l'ascenseur vers les étages des
étages très lumineux avec vue côté
fleuve ou côté parc tous les bureaux
sont à aire ouverte et les seules salles
fermées servent aux réunions ou aux
formations
l'idée une série assez cruel envers mon
travail de vie qui répondent bien aux
besoins des employés on le sait
aujourd'hui les enjeux d'attraction de
rétention de la main-d'oeuvre est
important donc l'environnement de
travail qu'on leur offre est primordial
pour entre 6h du matin et minuit ils
sont mille employés se relayer ici
il travaille en grande majorité pour le
centre d'appels et de conseils clients
de desjardins
ils ont entre autres accès à une salle
de jeux un plusieurs coins repos et à
une grande cafétéria au deuxième étage
c'est motivant de se lever chaque matin
puis devenir travail puis à la tour on a
de belles vues que c'est ce qui en est
ainsi c'est encore une fierté
supplémentaire
quand on dit que on travaillait à la
tour on sent un petit peu plus important
je me dirais long girex et un impact
majeur sur mobilisation qu'on a moins ne
parle que prévu en octobre ce qui
coïncide avec les pratiques malhonnêtes
est arrivé parce que c'est dû à sow mais
c'est sûr que s'il ya un effet à tout
coup sûr l'attraction définition des
jardins occupe maintenant 80 % de
l'espace alloué de la tour du stade soit
les 7 premiers étages sur 12
les cinq autres étages supérieurs
beaucoup plus petits pour éventuellement
être loués également à d'autres
entreprises par la régie des
installations olympiques
la rio a dépensé 140 4 millions de
dollars pour rénover sa tour des jardins
elle préfère ne pas donner de chiffre et
les sommes qui ont été dépensées sont
très représentatives en fait de ce genre
de construction on n'est vraiment pas
dans l'excès nulle part on ne pas
minimiser non plus les investissements
pour les employés
un avenir rapproché desjardins n'exclut
pas de louer aussi le 8e étage de la
tour que l'on voit ici
l'entreprise a signé un bail de 15 ans
avec la rio avec une option pour le
prolonger ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal